we are inside one of the trauma bays
here at the university of arkansas for
medical sciences we have been given
unprecedented access
in order to tell you this story there
are 23 coveted beds in the hospital but
56 coveted patients in fact seven of
them came in overnight and that's a lot
to come in on one night
the average age of a coveted patient
inside the hospital right now
is 40 years old
i thought the vaccine was a hoax 42 year
old lamonte boyd
a married father of three says he didn't
listen to the doctors or even his wife
when she got the covet vaccine and told
him he should too
what did you think of covid before you
got sick mr boyd
i brushed it off i thought it was a joke
there are going to be a lot of people
watching who don't want to take the
vaccine
what would you say to them well i tell
those who don't want to take the
vaccines
you you you you playing russian roulette
with your lives
boyd was diagnosed with covid19 nearly
two weeks ago
he developed pneumonia in both of his
lungs and still
right now as we talk my wind is short
that's why
you know i'm really gasping for here now
arkansas
has the third lowest full vaccination
rate in the country a little over one in
three people here have gotten both of
their shots
the state is now in its third surge says
dr cam patterson who is chancellor at
arkansas's only academic medical center
to put it into perspective our team is
in the fourth quarter right now
or maybe even double overtime this is
not the first quarter for this team
they're tired
it's tough dr patterson has stood
alongside the governor
many times over the last year educating
arkansans about how effective the
vaccines are
to those people who are still skeptical
he says this help me to understand who
would convince you
if i haven't convinced you help me to
understand who
would and i will find that person and we
will talk to you
i regret it not getting the closet
vaccination this 62 year old woman did
not want to give us her name
but she did want to speak for this story
it's hard
to breathe so i have to have oxygen
you can see it on me 24
7 and then there's occasions where
i cough and i can't stop what would you
say to all those people
who are spreading misinformation about
the vaccine
it's a life or death
sentence it's not a joke
consider this since january of this year
98 of the covet patients hospitalized
here in the state of arkansas
were all unvaccinated 98
think about that anthony back to you all
right david thank you